[Música]
en la década de 1920 el matemático
alemán david hilbert creó un famoso
ejercicio mental para mostrarnos lo
difícil que es entender el concepto de
infinito imaginen un hotel con una
cantidad infinita de habitaciones y un
gerente nocturno muy eficiente una noche
el hotel infinito está completamente
lleno totalmente ocupado con una
cantidad infinita de huéspedes un hombre
llega al hotel y pide una habitación en
vez de despacharlo el gerente nocturno
decide conseguirle una habitación como
fácil le pide al huésped de la
habitación número uno que se pase a la
habitación número dos al huésped de la
habitación número dos a la habitación
número tres y así sucesivamente todos
los huéspedes se mueven de la habitación
número n a la habitación número n 1
como hay una cantidad infinita de
habitaciones hay una habitación para
cada huésped esto deja la habitación
número uno vacía para el nuevo huésped
el proceso puede repetirse para
cualquier número infinito de nuevos
huéspedes si digamos llega un autobús
con 40 nuevos huéspedes en busca de
habitaciones entonces todos los
huéspedes alojados se pasan de la
habitación número n a la habitación
número n + 40 va siendo así las 40
primeras habitaciones
pero ahora un autobús infinitamente
largo con un infinito numerables de
pasajeros llega para alquilar cuartos
infinito numerables es la clave el bus
infinito con infinitos pasajeros deja
inicialmente atónito al gerente nocturno
pero ve que hay una forma de darle
hospedaje a todos le pide al huésped de
la habitación 1 que se pase a la
habitación 2 luego al de la habitación 2
que se pase a la habitación 4 al de la
habitación 3 a la habitación 6 y así
sucesivamente
todos los huéspedes se pasan de la
habitación número n a la habitación
número 2 n
llenando únicamente las habitaciones con
número infinitos pares al hacer esto se
han vaciado todas las habitaciones con
números infinitos impares que son
ocupados por las personas que venían en
el bus infinito
y todo el mundo está feliz y el negocio
del hotel prospera más que nunca bueno
de hecho está prosperando exactamente de
la misma forma que siempre cobrando una
suma infinita de dólares por noche
se corre la voz sobre este hotel
increíble viene gente de todas partes
una noche ocurre lo más inesperado el
gerente el autor no mira hacia afuera y
ve una cola infinita de buses
infinitamente largos todos con una
cantidad innumerable infinita de
pasajeros que puede hacer si no puede
conseguir las habitaciones del hotel
perderá una cantidad infinita de dinero
y él ciertamente perderá el trabajo
con suerte se acuerda que alrededor del
año 300 antes de cristo euclides
demostró que hay una cantidad infinita
de números primos así que para lograrlo
lo que parece una tarea imposible de
conseguir camas infinitas para buses
infinitos con infinitos viajeros
cansados el gerente nocturno le asigna a
todos los huéspedes existentes el primer
número primo 2 elevado a la potencia del
número de su habitación así que el
huésped de la habitación 7 pasa a la
habitación 2 a la séptima que es la
habitación 128
el gerente nocturno toma a todas las
personas en el primero de los buses
infinitos y le asigna las habitaciones
del próximo número primo 3 elevado al
número de sus asientos en el bus así que
la persona de las 107 del primer bus se
hospedará en la habitación 3 a la
séptima oa la habitación
2.187 así continúa para todos en el
primer bus a los pasajeros del segundo
bus se les asignan los exponentes de 5
el próximo primo el siguiente bus
exponente es de 7 así continúa con los
buses que siguen exponentes de 11
exponentes de 13 exponentes de 17
etcétera como cada uno de estos números
sólo tienen 1 y números naturales como
exponentes de estos números primos no
hay una superposición en los números a
todos los pasajeros de los buses se les
asigna una habitación empleando un
sistema de asignación único basados en
números primos únicos de esta forma el
gerente nocturno puede alojar a todos
los pasajeros en todos los buses sin
embargo habrá habitaciones que quedarán
vacías como la habitación 6 porque el 6
no es la potencia de ningún número primo
con suerte sus jefes no muy buenos en
matemáticas así que su trabajo está
asegurado las estrategias del gerente
nocturno son sólo posibles porque aunque
el otro infinito es ciertamente una
pesadilla logística solo tiene que
lidiar con números infinitos bajos
principalmente los infinitos contables
de los números naturales como 1 2 3 4 y
así george cantor denominó este nivel de
infinito al f 0 usamos números naturales
en las habitaciones así como en los
asientos de los buses si tuviésemos que
lidiar con niveles de infinito más altos
como el de los números reales estas
estrategias estructuradas no serían
posibles porque no hay manera de que
podamos incluir sistemáticamente todos
los números en el hotel infinito de los
números reales tendría habitaciones con
números negativos en el sótano
habitaciones con fracciones de modo que
el huésped de la habitación un medio
siempre sospechar a que tiene menos
espacio que el huésped en la habitación
número 1 habitaciones a la raíz cuadrada
como la habitación radical de dos la
habitación con huéspedes que piden
postres gratis que gerente nocturno que
se respete querría trabajar allí así sea
por un salario infinito pero en el hotel
infinito de gilbert donde nunca hay una
vacante y siempre hay más cuarto los
escenarios que enfrenta el siempre muy
diligente quizás demasiado hospitalario
gerente nocturno nos sirven para
recordarnos lo difícil que es para
nuestras mentes relativamente finitas
entender un concepto tan grande como el
infinito quizás puedan ayudar a abordar
estos problemas después de la buena
noche de descanso aunque honestamente
quizás tengamos que cambiarlos de
habitación a las dos de la mañana
está listo para poner a prueba su lógica
con otro sensacional enigma entérese si
puede ser más listo que un señor supremo
alienígena con este vídeo y suscríbase a
nuestro canal para continuar mejorando
sus habilidades de resolución de enigmas